seth rogen is sharing his thoughts on
the academy awards with the show's
continual declining viewership morgan
has a lot to say about this i'm very
excited about
speaking with an insider seth admits he
doesn't get the big deal about the show
saying this
i don't get why movie people care so
much of other people care what awards we
give ourselves to me maybe people just
don't care yeah seth also made a point
about other industries awards adding i
don't care who wins the automobile
awards no other industry expects
everyone to care about what awards they
shower upon themselves maybe people just
don't care maybe they did for a while
and they stopped caring and why should
they an insider points out last year's
oscars drew the lowest ratings in the
show's history with under 10 million
people watching this year's show is set
to air on sunday march 27th uh in an
effort to raise viewership this year's
ceremony will have a host for the very
first time since 2018. okay go morgan
you go first so here's the thing you
know we have been talking about how
award shows big award shows you know
have we've seen this big decline in
viewership now listen the past two years
people are trying to make it virtual
they've been awkward uh they're never
super smooth it was fun at the beginning
to see people in their homes and now i
think you know either people want it to
go back to the way it was or
something has been lost and i will agree
with that because you know my family
used to have oscar parties we were like
obsessed and we
you know they stopped watching it you
know before the pandemic before lockdown
um i don't know you know the more i'm
gonna be super honest because you know
obviously we work on an entertainment
show i love talking about celebrities i
love movies i love tv shows um
i love gossip
but you know when you you hear more and
more about the metoo movement and you
know the big studios and you know people
have made life very very difficult for a
lot of people the industry in general
doesn't feel like a place that i think a
lot of people want to celebrate do we
want to celebrate the movies and the
actors and sure but i don't know there's
something that has turned for a lot of
people i think in terms of wanting to
celebrate this industry that we used to
put on this huge platform and you know
the more stories you hear it's
not been a very nice place for a lot of
people right i also think that social
media plays a big part in it yeah you
get that juicy bit you get to see your
star any time of day you want it's true
on the social media you get way more
than when you get a clip of someone
glamorous up on a red carpet yeah i also
think that
these shows have not evolved no slams
against the producers but these shows
have not evolved
at least with the grammys when you have
musical acts like you're telling a story
each time a new person goes up i think
the academy award you have to have a
host number one for sure number two i
think less awards number three i think
skits i think skits i think
performance is that what you're saying
yeah almost like a sketch show like but
acting out pieces of a movie like i
don't know but you have to up the
entertainment value of these shows you
cannot expect people to sit and watch
people
eat their dinner walk up receive an
award over and over again with no
entertainment
our society sees 15 second clips of
really entertaining stuff you are you
are prone to
enjoying something like that there is no
serotonin spike on these award shows and
i think that's a huge problem yeah you
know a lot of people were talking about
the movie so paul's saying it was hard
enough to care when it was easy to go to
a theater to see all of the nominees now
i haven't even heard half of them and
the pandemic doesn't make it easier to
see all of the movies and with that said
you know there was a real big push this
year um from disney you know because
we're seeing you know you have this idea
of superhero films and you think oh it's
just for visual effects but right we've
seen some fantastic stories some
fantastic performances spiderman no way
home is a great example uh shang chi is
another great example um
and and i think a lot of people were
hoping we were going to like where is it
and they got shut out and that was a
huge thing and i do think that's a bit
of an issue because that could have
brought in a whole other group of people
watching a thousand percent and you know
not to make it like the mtv awards you
know we those movies do get their own
time and space but you know
they're really good they've really
stepped up their games so maybe i don't
know the orchards just need to look at
you know what what the nominees should
be going forward i don't know
great comment shake it up yeah and yes
he's saying you can also watch clips on
your own later
there you go yeah the shows need to be
different